hello and welcome to this video playing
chess ft w for the win right yeah let's
go for the green felt experimental mode
I have no idea about the opening or
let's say very little idea yeah they all
play Queen 85 here in this position I
have no idea why exactly do I need to do
that is d 5 a threat here maybe yeah I
don't know I just have to UM yeah invent
stuff him it's it bad to play something
like that taking is not a problem ever
maybe d5 is an issue yeah ok go's t5 ok
he's six yeah I guess I have to attack
the center right ok Jim I mean at least
I can't develop rather comfortably night
would be great on d6 but this is one of
those ideas that yeah that never will
materialize maybe I can do this and play
Bishop to g5 preventing castling for the
moment mmm maybe that's not so bad get
this out now
and I have I'm blocking the deep on for
the Moon Knight f6 cat6 that would be
great but is that possible now I have
success probably bishop age 6 there is
no other routine I can go f5 this is a
more aggressive way of doing things
maybe I mean he doesn't have a night
anymore so there is no Knight coming to
a 6 all of a sudden at F form and now I
can go Knight f6 Bishop deform would be
good okay pin and win well he pecan pin
but probably not win hmm but how to do
it let's play a strengthening mafia with
the king should be four maybe mmhmm yeah
I don't know if that really helps right
Bishop do you form yeah but why not it
should be a little bit more active there
and Knight g4 might be a move the right
circumstance 96 is a little bit tougher
to play now for him okay how this is Sir
this is decent I guess fortunately I
cannot so easily plane I g4s Bishop
takes the eight as a tempo on the Queen
okay not anymore so let you for now rook
e8 okay that's not bad anyway rook e8
night x f2 checked we never to Bishop f2
loopy 7 is a better ending oh here goes
with that we have a couple of good moves
Queenie fibers also not bad yeah this is
the most obvious choice but not sure
it's the best one let's go for this
again creamy five and the night / 26
would be great or just 94 for a very
good ending so taking that okay let's
cover should have the time to do that
let's get it over to d6 efore 96 it's
also an awkward pin ok check-in queen
before I'm not sure that this helps much
yeah it's nice but it's not clear how
I'm making the decisive progress here
that I want a 6b five so also not
helping much okay I'm going for this
Bishop h5 I go G for the bishop is is
kind of trapped okay Chad see if I if he
goes for the ending now or if you know
he goes for the ending check and check
me though yeah check okay
yeah i think i have to prevent the
depart from moving for the moment b5 is
probably not that time morning was that
helpful check yeah i wonder if that is
good here asics Butler not easy to play
yeah be fat XXX root g5 it's not so
convincing hmm really isn't now and I
have less time
I really wonder why we're slipped here
you can even go 85 and this might be
better for him check yeah now that's not
good nah or we looked at one ah damn i
was awful i was really awful black
resins very bad end game play by me yeah
here widest widest completely busted I
just have to do it right and I'm really
played it badly I have to go age four
just just play with all the pieces on
the board yeah yeah it's not so
difficult even though I thought that
ending should be better as well but it
wasn't really wasn't yeah this is minus
two points something why chess what is
running out of moves in this position
what is he supposed to do something like
that I go and I go here now just have to
keep everything on the board it was
actually I really like this game I think
I played it played it fine this is I
mean I always have to have to be take
into account that i have no experience
with those positions but i felt that
this was kind of okay with regrouping
and then a five and that was okay I'm
think I'm good here at least its kind of
equal i guess and then yeah then yeah he
he came up with Bishop e3 after which
she
just clearly worse and now God term yeah
this is just Chang the other job the
other continuation is just better I mean
okay I should not use here of course but
ah no asics was bad it was also just a
bad move check until b5 you know I'm not
sure about this this is sir yes it's
count to play there yeah I can play that
was he form but that's not an advantage
anymore the way I played however I was
worse and we brought the rook over to f4
yeah i mean i should just stay here like
with Regev six or so it was probably I
was panicking with less time and it's
just they're just a bad move yeah I'm
losing yeah that was very bad ending
plane I should play play this effort age
for business and just continue to check
his bad King bad King position alright a
little bit of a shame okay thanks for
watching